[Music]
well welcome to another episode of the
addie hour it's my pleasure to be able
to host these conversations and to
really continue to talk about topics
that i think are central and important
for us as a society
and so today i'm again honored to be
able to welcome two guests from
different walks of life who are going to
be able to share their unique
experiences
but also share some parallels and
overlapping themes as well
the topic for today's conversation will
be where do we go from here
and i think in a lot of ways this is a
highly relevant topic and conversation
i mean to be completely honest it seems
like we're just going from one tragic
event to the next
on a weekly basis sometimes on a daily
basis and so i think it's really
important for us to be able to sit back
and process how we actually move through
that
so i'm honored to be able to host
today's two guests the first
is dr amy arnstein and abe arnstein
is the albert e kent professor of
psychology and neuroscience at yale
she directs a research lab where she
looks at and researches the processes
and circuits in the brain
that are affected by stress and by aging
and how those can lead to cognitive
deficits she's made a whole host of
different research
seminal research contributions to the
field over the years
she's also a member of the prestigious
national academy of medicine
and so we're thrilled to have amy here
with us one thing i will say one of the
things i really appreciate in addition
to all the accolades is how amy leads
with passion
this is something you can see in the
classroom when she's teaching
in the research lab and in how she
engages in society
so amy welcome to the addie hour
definitely grateful to have you here
with us today
thank you so much nate a joy to be here
our second guest is none other than
lecrae lecrae is a multi-grammy
award-winning platinum summoning artist
who has evolved into a new york times
best-selling author
entrepreneur speaker thought leader and
philanthropist
all while co-owning and serving as
president of reach records
so he's someone who's had a lot of
impact in a lot of different spheres
he's also sold millions of copies of his
music worldwide has won multiple grammy
awards dove awards
a soul trained music award and also has
a b had a bet
hip hop nomination but again in addition
to all the accolades one thing i really
appreciate about him
is how invested he is in community and
how he has continued to make those
investments in several different ways
one of those more recent has been all
the initiatives that he's taken part in
and really trying to rebuild the west
side of metro atlanta
in addition to other things that he's
done in the atlanta area and worldwide
so really grateful to have lacrae here
on the program with us today as well
thanks for being here
honor honor sincerely
so we're ready to jump into this
conversation and excited to really
think deeply about this aspect of where
we try and go from here
for any of you who are regular listeners
you know one of the things i like to do
is really to check in with our guests
first just to see
how you're doing in the midst of
everything that's going on
clearly this has been an another tragic
week for us as
a society with ongoing killings of black
men and boys at the hands of police
um and it's heavy i mean that's an
honestly heavy place to be i mean i can
say personally a lot of times i move
through a lot of different emotions when
those things come up
there's a feeling sometimes of personal
fear just being completely honest
there's feelings of frustration
anger there's feelings of exhaustion and
tiredness and sometimes i know i even
shift towards
being a little bit numb to just seeing
this kind of happening over and over
again
and at the same time i know that i have
a deep need and desire for healing
and hope so it's really a mixture of
things and it you know kind of moves
depending on the day and where i'm at
any specific point in time
but i thought it would be really good
for all of us the three of us here and
for our listeners to really at least
start out
talking through how you're dealing with
everything that's going on
in society and even in your personal
lives um so amy if we could go ahead and
start with you if you'd be willing to
share
sure um and i also feeling uh
weary from such a continued stress
uh much of the past year for me
personally i was so worried about my
mother who's um 99 which is wonderful
but she was in an assisted living
facility and it was a real race between
the virus and the vaccine and thank god
she got the vaccine um and it was the
same thing you know with the
election where it was just this um
overwhelming anxiety and thankfully
biden won but at this point when you
know i have this very
childish feeling of oh can't it all be
all better now
and instead dealing now with
the real problems that are still very
much there so for example
my mother has gone blind on how to help
her and then at a
national level you know today as we
talk just the national anxiety about
what's going to happen in the
children trial you know um and i think
over the past four years so much
got exposed about the many weaknesses in
america
that we had so hoped had had really been
solved a lot more
than it has and this realization
we have a long way to go and
um that's going to take
a lot of help um we have to really
take care of ourselves and each other if
we're going to make progress
and to relate to today's conversation i
find for myself
that understanding how the brain
responds to stress has
really helped me have compassion for
myself when i'm feeling
inadequate and not living up to what i
hope to be
and i think it's wonderful to have this
opportunity to share this here today
because i think
compassion and forgiveness whether they
come from science
or religion or art helps us to heal
and can give us that strength we need
that's so well said and thank you for
sharing so honestly about
even the personal challenges and what
the places that you find hope and
healing in the midst of this as well
lagree what about you how are you
imagining at this current moment
well you know it's interesting
um i think
you know 2016 is when i really bro
20 2014 through 16 is when i
really uh found myself hyper focused on
a lot of the um racial tensions and
political tensions in america
and i did not consider how it would
personally affect me i think i just went
in
blind and not recognizing the real i
didn't understand
uh the science of stress or anxiety or
depression any of those things
um and i just you know uh
stuffed all of those emotions and
feelings deep down inside which
ultimately resulted in a mental
breakdown
and i think from 2018
until now i'm so much more aware
of you know
what hyper focusing on all of those
particular things
can do to me and so um
i think in this season of life i'm i'm
working to
process solutions i'm working to process
um how we can navigate and in the in
in positive things that we can we can do
in light of it all because i think you
can become a nihilist
in a lot of ways if you just look at how
crazy everything is so for me
um i've been trying to be helpful
in as many ways as possible um i've been
trying to figure out how do we
how do we uh invest in
potential dante rights um invested
in in the younger generation of george
floyd's
um to create awareness and insight
so that they can find themselves in a in
a healthier
place in life and um and then at the
same time
um you know thinking through
um you know what it looks like to
communicate
empathy to um law enforcement and people
on the other side of the aisle
and so uh all that to say uh
to get super scientific uh for some
people
i am believing in neuroplasticity i am
trying to focus on new things
so that changes can happen and healing
can occur in my mind
well said well i was joking before we
got on there we were going to flip the
rose a little bit
have lecrae expand on the neuroscience
and have amy talk about
her experiences with music and there's
room for that there's room for that
but i appreciate you sharing you know a
little bit of the journey as well um
and both of what you've shared both from
you know personal experiences and what
you've tried to do the crab be curious
to hear you expand on that even a little
bit more on what you
because you talked about how you've
gotten to this place what have you
seen be effective in your journey and on
the flip side
things that you would also say that have
been ineffective that you would have
avoided that you would do differently
going forward
yeah i think um one is
is is understanding your limitations
you know there are certain things that
you can know about but you may not need
to
to see um and i think in this the age
we're in
um i'm grateful for
the accountability of video but it
doesn't mean i need to watch all the
videos
doesn't mean that's healthy for me uh to
see
people being murdered uh via via video
um and so part of it for me is
is not inundating myself with that
um with those visual with those visuals
um you know figuring out okay what am i
doing what kinds of things can i do
that make me feel like i'm investing and
i'm
working toward change um i think that's
been helpful for me
um and then more or less
is um in light of everything going on
societally
is i've i've had to find myself where's
where does my hope lie
and what am i grateful for and and how
can i meditate on those
particular things more often um
the things that i wish i would have done
different is
i i think that um
i found myself very hyper focused on
all of the negativity and i did not look
historically at the change that had
occurred
and that what what it may take to see
more change occur i just looked at
you know the the kind of the pessimistic
side of everything
and um and i just found myself very
low and uh very uh it was a dark time
and um and if i could go back i think i
would have
learned that hyper focusing on all that
was not healthy for me
um yeah that makes a lot of sense i
think that's something we'll probably
come back to in this conversation too
even thinking about how we how we get
into that hyper focused state and what's
happening in our brain that allows that
to occur in ways to even manage that
i think it's also great that you brought
the idea of hope and healing as well and
amy you were hinting at that
and mentioning that when you talked
about your perspective with neuroscience
as well
so i'd be curious if you could share for
listeners how you got into this journey
or your journey to get to this place of
thinking about the neuroscience
of stress and resilience and then also
how that helps you even more so with the
hope that you were talking about
sure i actually began um
wondering about neuroscience and stress
when i was a teenager
we had a lot of illness and death in my
family with loved ones
when i was that age and i
watch as um like my parents um people
around me
who you rely on as a kid and suddenly
they're this
this swirl you know there's there's a
quick sound there
you can't rely on them anymore because
they weren't thinking straight
and i i actually began
volunteering at the state psychiatric
hospital in new jersey to learn more
about mental illness and it shows how
old i am that this was a time when
um there were these um huge hospitals
um 2000 patients and you can argue
whether that was better than having
people out on the street homeless
but volunteering there i got to know
several patients quite well and one
gentleman
had schizophrenia and had been an
astrophysicist
we were able to talk about astronomy in
this great way
totally logical you'd never know he was
ill
and then one day while we're doing that
someone mentioned the name of this
really cruel
doctor and just hearing that man's name
um this gentleman just instantly
dissolved into what's called
word salad thought disorder one
clanging uh phrase after another that
really didn't make sense
and then as he calmed down he his
thoughts re-congealed
and we continued our talk about the
solar system
and it was like this explosive seed
crystal to me
of this shows i
have to understand what stress does to
the brain because it's such a clue
as to what's underlying um so many
disorders including schizophrenia
and so i've really studied it ever since
and
and thankfully we've been able to make a
lot of
progress and and what we've learned we
meaning the field as well as me
that when you have a stress that makes
you feel
out of control that's a key part of it
if you
feel up to it uh these toxic changes
don't happen but if you feel threatened
or out of control
you get this flood of chemicals that
takes what's called the prefrontal
cortex offline
and the prefrontal cortex is one of our
most newly
evolved parts of our brain that observes
abstract reasoning top-down control
so you really need it when you're going
through a complex
stressor in particular and at the same
time this flood of stress
chemicals strengthens our primitive
circuits that make us
unconsciously react our emotional
reactions and habits
so it's this double whammy where you're
losing
your rational cheerleader and at the
same time strengthening these primitive
reactions
and um your brain can really get in a
rut
where it it develops a vicious cycle and
gets stuck there
and so a large part of what my lab is
trying to
do is understand what is it that makes
prefrontal cortex
weak versus stronger so we can develop
medication
so if you're in a rut you can
get some help on getting to a healthier
place so
it's it's been a long journey because
i'm an old woman
but i can really place it back to
those childhood experiences yeah that's
really powerful i mean to know that that
initial experience has such a
long-term impact on you and your
trajectory and your passion
i think that that says a lot and the
fact that you're i mean it sounds and
you're you're motivated
by the people that you're serving in a
lot of ways
as well yeah very much and sometimes
that person's me
mm-hmm yeah so what uh i'd be curious to
hear even more about that how
how does that part come into play the
person being you
because i know you know it's it's a
tension and sometimes there are ways
that
different of us as scientists kind of
reconcile that in different ways so it'd
be great to hear
you know how you've done that over the
years well some of it is
when i find myself um uh losing it
you know look i was saying finding your
limits
and um i've also really come to say okay
i can feel that my brain is not going
into a good place
stop watching the news for hours on end
you know
let's go for a walk in the woods um that
um knowing what your own limits are and
what makes you feel better which is
individual for everybody but
learning that and so you can take care
of yourself
better and i'm also taking one of the
medications my lab
discovered but that's because i'm an old
lady i'm not just
a stressed person
yeah well i mean i think that's that's
powerful in a lot of ways and i
appreciate your
your honesty and sharing that as well
who can say that who can say
i'm making the medication my lab
discovered
that's just like i don't know i have no
comprehension of this
it's amazing it is that's a good point
we don't know if it's working though
okay
we can we can ask those around you i
have a feeling they would say it's
working
look great how do you i mean your
reactor but how do you react to
even the components that amy's talking
about in terms of how the brain's
working like does that
hearing that now and thinking backwards
to what you've already talked about does
that give you
even a way to interpret some of the
things that you were saying yeah
i mean it's just i'm fascinated
um i think like
organizing chaos is something that's
very fascinating for me
you know and i think um the the idea
that
i walk through life and
you know all the chaos that just
ensues and i i i didn't have categories
for what was happening i didn't have
language for it like
oh this is stress i'm feeling you know
what i mean i don't i don't think i had
a context for it
and then even to go steps deeper and
talk about well my prefrontal cortex
isn't working properly and you know all
those things are very helpful
um some things are just
obvious to us i really i'm
i'm grateful for the the
um kind of playing field being leveled
as it pertains to mental health
um more so because
i don't think people think it's as
scientific
as it is i think they they find
they find themselves connecting their
brain
to their essence
you know like your identity in a lot of
ways
and your biology is not the full extent
of your identity sometimes
it's kind of like like right now people
don't know i'm i'm wearing contact
lenses
but my identity is not that i can't i
don't think of like oh my gosh i need
contact so i'm a terrible person
you know what i mean i don't think like
that i think how can i
fix this blindness that i suffer from
you know do i wear some glasses or i
would put in some contacts and then i
can move forward but it's not like a
crushing
weight on my worth and my value but
oftentimes in
my brain not functioning as it should
like a disorder
you tend to say i'm
terrible you know what i mean like i
didn't know like i have
uh add i don't know if it's adhd but
it's definitely 80d
um and i didn't know that as a kid i
just thought i was this
impulsive mischievous rat irrational
person
and now as an adult it's like oh
i wish i would have known that and so i
think it's very
insightful and it's comforting uh to
hear
you know amy talk about these things it
gives me comfort
you know that's really well said i'm so
glad
because it does that for me too yeah
yeah yeah
i think that's a place that we all need
to be in a lot of ways i mean even the
point
you brought up about leveling the
playing field does not you know not to
be too
pejorative to justice academics but we
have this tendency to get stuck in our
bubble
we don't talk to anybody about the
science outside that bubble and then we
don't even
interpret it for our own cells so i mean
amy i think everything you're talking
about i mean i see that
as unique in a lot of ways as reflective
as you've been about your work and your
own emotions as you're walking through
that and being able to i mean you know
the fancy word people use as
metacognition to be able to think about
your
thinking and what you're going through
while it's happening
and to be able to have those tools i
think it makes it even that much more
powerful to talk about your experience
so that those outside of the scientific
realm can learn from it and actually
apply it and see that we're applying it
in our own lives
that's why i mean i think that i think
that's huge
well and and just to remind her that
often you can't do that in the moment
because stress is taking exactly those
circuits offline but then
not being mad at yourself about that and
going back and revisiting and
and having that yeah yeah yeah so i
don't think people
sit back and and tell themselves like oh
man my prefrontal cortex is
short-circuiting right now like it's
yeah it's just good
[Laughter]
so i mean on that note that's actually a
great segue because i'm curious you know
we started this out thinking about where
do we go from here how do we take
all these principles that you all are
talking about and apply them
right now in our current situation maybe
not in the moment
as we're seeing an another unjust
killing occurring
but in this moment as we're conversing
and thinking about how are we going to
deal with that if and when it happens
again
[Music]
any thoughts you want to jump in with to
start off
um i want to go back to what we just
said to add one more thought
that um i think it's helpful
to think of mental health as a
continuous spectrum
that there's this
continuum between health and illness
and also that a strength in one context
can be a weakness in another
including with atd there's times when
when having that kind of
energy and being distracted by something
that's just
occurred can be life-saving for a person
or a community
who's with that person so um
i think that helps reduce stigma and and
gives us
it's both more realistic but also more
compassionate view
uh about brain health and um
the recognition that if you've
had either genetic insults a physical
insult
an emotional or physical trauma that
those are times when you need
extra self-care recognizing limits
that can shift and and one can be more
fragile
as the cry was talking about so um
really taking care of our
our minds brains the way many people
take care of their bodies
with working out and i think some people
are
already trying to do that with like
drinking caffeine
um but doing it in a much broader way
with all the needs
and and that that can help um give us
a more effective view on mental health
for what you were just saying um
this idea of how
do we help ourselves feel more in
control
and uh give ourselves what we need
to be able um to
help our self be our better self again
and it's so
individual um so it's again you have to
really know
who you are what are your triggers
what are the things that help to make
you feel better
and important that they're the things
that don't make you feel
worse in the morning so alcohol
drugs can make you temporarily feel
better but then you're
worse what are the things that give you
sustained goodness even if it isn't so
dramatic instantly it's really there for
you
for the long run and and i think
um there's many things uh for some
people it's things like
meditation and and exercise oh and
uh that reminds me i got a call once
from ariana huffington
who was writing a piece on the civil
rights leaders of the 20th century
and how they had to do self-care
to get themselves through um the long
haul
and how like rosa parks did yoga and so
they really recognized something
right from the start this is going to be
a very very long and hard
mission we have to take care of
ourselves and
and i think we have forgotten that and
are happy
to really discover it and so
the kinds of things that can help people
um um feeling
gratitude gaining perspective
from that from walking through the woods
is one of the things i like to do
um through community through
artistic expression and music in
particular i think can be
particularly effective because music is
so much about emotion
both expressing it and receiving it by
listening to it
and my son is also a musician so i get
to watch this close up
and i get to see the comments on
his youtube videos just like with
lecrae's where people are saying
i have just lost this loved one and your
music has made
all the difference to me giving me hope
again
someone who was suicidal and listening
to the music
gave them what they needed to keep going
on so i
i think um blessings
rhyming with stressings is really
important look
so thank you well said
i know you're gonna bring out some
lyricism i'm impressed
very impressed bravo bravo
that's that's great uh i would i would
wholeheartedly
agree um with so much of what she said i
think
you know i i look at my own life
in light of everything you know i was
i experienced a lot of historic trauma i
was abused
um i experienced neglect
um you know i'm the men i looked up to
i was oftentimes visiting them in prison
and
and so i didn't realize those are all
contributing factors
to my my development and
um and my mental health and so
i look i look at it like you know the
average person
if you think about their stress level as
like a paper towel
um you know when you put
if you've got a paper towel on top of a
cup or something like that and
you put some i don't know some rice on
top of that paper towel
uh it's gonna sink down but if there's
like a rubber band around it you know
it'll sustain and hold the rice well i
look at my historical trauma
as like drips of water on my paper towel
you know and so when someone puts the
rice on it
i'm more vulnerable i'm more vulnerable
to
to to having a breakdown to having that
that that stress
snap and i think that's what's
currently been helpful for me i didn't
know this in 2014 through 2016.
i didn't know that so i'm engaging these
stressful circumstances not realizing
that i'm dealing with a wet paper towel
and
now it's like i know i have a sensitive
brain
right like i'm my brain is sensitive
uh it's hypersensitive you know
i get false alarms in terms of anxiety
all the time and so
um i have to
in knowing that i can
think more rationally and i probably
have to spend more time on she was just
talking about rosa parks doing yoga
um i spend more time meditating on truth
i think if you
if you you know they say that uh people
who know
counterfeit money they don't study
counterfeit money
they study real money so well that when
they see counterfeit
um they they can find they can pick it
out immediately and that's kind of what
i find myself having to do
i have to spend time
meditating on what is true and what is
good
and not irrational things
so that when this false alarm gets
triggered in my brain
i can say that's not what this is that's
not what's happening right now
and so you know
someone gets murdered on national
television
i think it's it's it's stressful to
anyone right
but for me i can
without having meditated on on what's
true
i can get very irrational and think this
is the end
you know it's gonna happen for me this
is i don't know my kids are
you know and i can just start spinning
out of control irrationally
which makes like chaos happen and so i
have to meditate and say hey listen
you know what's true about this okay uh
can you absolutely prove
that someone's gonna kick in your door
tonight and kill your kids
no i can't so let's not go there you
know what i mean let's not get too
wound up in that particular place and
and i found that that's been very
helpful for me
is really meditating on what i i know is
true to fight back that hyper
sensitivity going on in my brain now
that's so good and that ties in it makes
me think of one of the points that you
made earlier too
you're not to get too far outside the
scope but you talked about both sides of
the aisle
you know for us as black men in this
country but also for those who are in
law enforcement
because i have friends who are police
officers and if you have listened to
some of the commentary you know with
what happened to the
individual that was in the armed
services that got pulled over people
have been talking about
the mental state or the hyper-vigilance
state that the police were in when they
pulled that person over
what was going through their minds at
that moment
and yes and we i mean we also you know
have to talk about
those situations too and those
individuals where they're coming into
that situation from yes so i know i mean
being on the receiving end of that you
know being pulled over you know i was
coming back from a talk
that emery of all places got back at one
o'clock in the morning
on the way home lived in the part of
town that was kind of off the beaten
path and got pulled over one o'clock in
the morning
for no reason so you know everything
that's running through my mind i was
definitely in a hyper-vigilant state
but also thinking about the caucasian
female officer that was walking up to my
car
what was in her so i mean just
everything you've mentioned i don't
think we have those conversations enough
i don't know as much about the law
enforcement side but i feel like it's
something that has to be had
on both sides of the island that's
definitely a live conversation
in a lot of ways so again you know that
could be a whole another whole other
topic of discussion but i think
sometimes
we don't talk about what's happening in
the brains on both sides and how once
you put that together and i don't know
if there's anything you want to add from
your perspective about those stressors
that come on both sides of the album
that way
but oh yeah knowing how empathy is our
way out
absolutely you know you you can really
understand that when everybody's
stressed
um the worst things can happen and
forgiveness all around if you possibly
can how hard that is
and then why de-escalation
can be so helpful and that there are
programs and people out there who are
actively
trying to provide de-escalation some of
it based on the
neurobiology to
help people who are whose work
constantly puts them in these
threatening situations
yeah i think that's so important yeah
and clearly it doesn't it
doesn't justify anything that's happened
but i think it's a part of the
conversation that we need to really
seriously talk about well it's the
constructive way forward
exactly and and you know one
idea that's been lofted out there is
that maybe you don't have
uh law enforcement respond to every uh
emergency that comes up right if they if
they're trained to respond to
violent criminal activity maybe they
don't need to be called
for you know something that that doesn't
fall under that scale because
you're you're already hyper vigilant as
you said so
you're not thinking to de-escalate you
think you're in your fight-or-flight
mode and it's
it's just a speeding ticket you know
what i mean and you're in fighter flight
mode so
so maybe there's some restructuring
around all of that i have a friend
as well knee who's a police officer and
he told me a story of him
um you know he's he's a black man but he
he's chasing down um
someone who has a committed uh
a violent crime and uh was like a
domestic abuser when i'm mistaken
and he catches him and the guy
starts fighting him violently he's on
drugs and and
um you know he was in a situation where
he was like man
this guy is really dangerous and he had
to make a decision
in that moment like
as this guy broke through a hold and
took off running
was it worth chasing after him and
getting into an
even more violent circumstance of
situation and he had to process that
but the crazy part about it was you know
after that call he's already
his emotions and everything is
heightened and he's got to respond to
another call that's nowhere near the
same type of circumstances
and how does he turn his brain down dial
it down
to deal with what's in front of him when
he's just left
a brawl you know uh with a violent
individual and so those are all the
circumstances that i don't think we're
talking about and we're processing
yeah yeah that's so true and amy all the
i mean all the tools you've been talking
about and the
processes and brain that we need to be
aware of it seems like they're all
coming into play we need to be
an essential part of those conversations
yeah
and and are there things like people who
are specialized in dealing
with mental health emergencies
who could be in that car and there to
help them
um you know have pharmacological tools
to deal with somebody who's who's um
really psychotic um
so that things with um physical force
don't need to be used as much yeah
much more thoughtful ways of how to
proceed and protect the police as well
as the other people yeah yeah yeah this
is so important i mean to be honest i
think that's something
we'll probably have a more full extended
conversation on
on this uh on this podcast at some point
because i think it's
one that it's happening in small pockets
but it really needs to be
a much larger and bigger conversation a
lot of ways so yeah
i was curious just you know as we talked
about you both have music ties but how
do you see
music tying into this as well amy talked
about the emotion
how does the music tie in both in terms
of like how we experience things and in
terms of the brain
like what what is the the power that's
there
i'm putting you on the spot i'll be
very speculative um
so in right-handed individuals
the left hemisphere is usually
what creates and understands language
whereas the
right hemisphere creates and understands
emotion in language and to me music
is the right hemisphere without
necessarily
the words and then of course we add
words in songs
um but you don't even need those to feel
the emotion
of songs so that's something i just
wondered about
um thinking about music as
um emotional expression that doesn't
even
need words that's well said
uh yeah i i i'm i would not have
been able to say it like that that's
great uh
uh i i i'm
in my understanding in the learning that
i've had one of the realizations that
i've had is that i've been writing
songs since i was a little kid and and
probably you know
around 2000 and i want to say the iphone
the iphone in terms of like uh
writing and taking notes and computers
and whatnot i think that was more
revolutionary for me anyway around 2011
and 2010 maybe
and so i wonder this is just me
being speculative as well but but i
wonder if all those years that i spent
time
actually using the motor skills to write
and to process
was helpful for my mental stability and
as i began to switch over
and use the keyboard and use my phone to
write
was i not getting all the same benefits
um
there was something therapeutic about
writing down those lyrics
and i and also in light of what amy just
said
i love creative expression i think it's
very helpful for me i think
you know it it connects with people
music does minor chords hit a certain
type of part of the mind in the brain
major chords get you more excited
but when i have to actually take the
creative musical expression
and then add concepts and words it
becomes a little tougher
it becomes a little more like of a push
up hill so i'm i'm wondering if there's
something to that and you might have
nailed
something there i know i need to have
words because it connects with people
but it's just very interesting that um
i can get a kick out of just playing on
the keys or you know hearing a
jazz a saxophone solo and it still
gives me that same emotion yeah
and it's especially an uphill push if
you have to make those words rhyme
[Laughter]
tell me about it tell me about it
yeah i'm working on it well there's
definitely something there i mean i'm
just thinking back
not to disclose too many too many uh
addie secrets to
my own songwriting days and just the
nostalgia that comes with it sometimes
too
like if i hear something i wrote 20
years 20 25 years ago the place it takes
me back to
um grant you know that's not i mean just
all the the positive triggering in a
sense
in some ways that's outside my realm of
expertise but
you all are making me now we need to
hear this music i didn't even
i knew that was dangerous don't worry i
won't let you forget about it i'm sorry
we'll bring it out we'll bring it out in
some shape or form
so me i also wrote songs when i was a
teenager
the two of us should put out an album
together
no okay let me find out that
it's it's got to happen now we need that
uh who knows when two neuroscientists
get together with connoisseurs
we need that well you got to be pulled
into this mix too
all right i'll see what i can do i'll
see if i have anything to contribute
you know the lyrics get a little too
lofty for me a little too academic for
me i'll try to
i'll try to you know be the person to to
make it make sense to the common person
well i was ready for you to make a
neuroscience comment when you were
starting to follow amy with that comment
about the music and you're writing
i was getting really excited about where
you're going to take it i well
listen i don't you know i know the
little bit that i do know and i
you know i'm understanding the motor
skills and the parts of the brain that
are trying to work together
and so on and so forth and so again like
i said i'm all about trying to find
um as much healing as possible and
um you know i i i'm it's
it's i'm i'm honored to be able to be in
conversations like this because i'm
always wondering like what are the new
advances what's gonna
i mean look at what's happening we got
my i drive
a car that if i push a button it it can
navigate itself through city streets as
we what's we got to figure something out
with the brain
you know what i mean yeah yeah it's
important and on a serious note too i
think it's i mean what you're doing by
pulling in those pieces and
communicating that to large audiences
that makes a difference too
because i think that's part of what has
to happen here we need to have and i
think you were both referring to that
earlier we need to
make sure that we communicate that that
is the brain that is involved in these
things
and not lose sight of that because
that's where some of the stigma comes
that's where some of the fear comes and
all the concerns about you know if i
broke my arm i'm going to take care of
that
and get it put in a cast so i can heal
but if it's my brain oh i don't want to
touch that or
you know just all all the reactions that
come with that so i think it's i think
it's critical
i think that's such an area for
improvement reducing stigma
from mental health within medicine
itself let alone within society
and also of course to make mental health
resources
so much more available and and
cheap yeah yeah i totally agree
yeah i think it's funny because to me
if i think about like a megaphone you
know megaphone is small on one end and
it's bigger on the other end
i feel like academia has the megaphone
turned the opposite way like
you got all this information and then
it's like it just gets kind of like
yeah how do we get this out here
to the general public so
yeah i love just like i'm trying to
figure out how to
get it out so yeah there's so much there
yeah so you know on purpose i've been
making youtube videos
and posting them on the yale medical
school youtube channel
to provide this information to the
public
to doctors who are not in the same field
about burnout for example especially
during covid
um so uh it is my own
little way of trying to get that
information out there and
me i sent you one of the links
that maybe you can put on the website
you can definitely put that up on the
website
great resource yeah that's wonderful
so i know we're running tight on time
but i did want to ask both of you what
what legacy are you trying to leave in
terms of your
we i mean all the things that we've
talked about like how are you trying to
make sure that that gets out and
continues to make an impact
uh to those around you amy i'll have you
uh you started with the youtube video so
i'll have you continue to expand
on that well i'm really hoping that
um we continue to make progress in
creating medications that really help us
be
our better selves or better angels
so that when you feel stuck and lost
there's something you can turn to
that's really healthy i
i also wanted to say something i
discovered
in preparing for today's discussion
i was thinking a lot about the power of
gratitude and forgiveness
and so i i looked and
said i wonder if anybody has looked at
what happens in the brain
when you're feeling those emotions and i
found a few studies
including one by the dimazio lab
and i was so struck that when you're
feeling
gratitude or forgiveness
it activates the same areas of
prefrontal cortex
that regita sinha who was your guest
last time
has shown are the very circuits that
help us overcome
the stress response so
a real neural basis for how those
feelings
may really help us overcome uh
the toxic effects of stress that's so
good
that's so good i mean going it goes back
to what i think about
but we're told in scripture a lot too in
terms of the importance
of serving others in some ways it's it
sounds to me like the neurobiological
basis of what that is doing and just
kind of ties
ties everything together wow that's
great
i i felt so too that um
it relates uh the song blessings
and religion and science all together
um by activating the ventromedial
prefrontal cortex
wow you tied that the way only you could
tie that together
yeah that's amazing i see that in the
lyric
lecrae will be listen
i don't know what to i can't you know
that's interesting that
she says that because you know my legacy
i i definitely feel like my legacy is to
figure out a way
um you know to
process the information that we
currently
have and uh to shrink
the amygdala so that it it uh
you know there's got to be a way to
shrink the amygdala and and to ignite
the frontal
the prefrontal cortex so that it can
communicate clearly to the amygdala
during stress
uh circumstances and i think if i can
just uh
you know write a song that would allow
that to happen then
the whole world has changed you know
clearly uh
that's my contribution and legacy
i feel a little bit scared by your
insight because there are studies that
maybe not strengthening but
up there looking at those exact pathways
so somehow you tapped into something
oh man um no but sincerely
i i i see myself as a bridge you know i
i live in a lot of different communities
um
obviously the faith-based community um
the african-american
community the music the musical
community
and um as someone who has
struggled with mental illness um
i've seen the benefit of the
scientific community being able to speak
to these places
and i want to be a bridge i think that
we've
we've seen um you know that's not the
only legacy that i want to live but as
specifically as a change to this yes um
we've seen
obviously within the black community
just like the
total like i don't know what therapy is
i don't know i don't you know i don't do
all that stuff
and and just them understanding the
necessity of a lot of these things um in
the musical community a lot of artists
and musicians are
are brilliant and struggling with mental
illness simultaneously
and they don't even realize that a lot
of their their art
is stemmed from depression or anxiety
or you know other types of disorders and
so just helping them
understand that relationship so that
they can find health um i don't think
it's coincidental that
you know the musician community has a
quote unquote 27 club where all these
artists
died at 27 years old you know
and so um and then obviously in the
faith-based community
to erase a lot of the stigmas as well i
think
there's this misconception that you know
the the the brain is
not a physical entity that it is all
spiritual and so
to take medication is unspiritual to
seek therapy outside of a pastor or
priest or whatnot is somehow uh
unbiblical
and so just to close those gaps uh would
be very
uh encouraging for me it's something
that i i strive
uh to be able to do and so yeah i would
love to see that happen
and i guess what i would say is this is
that i think that
um we're all in a in a band
and too many of us are playing solos and
we sound a lot better when we play
together
you know when we when all this stuff is
mixed together and
now there's information that is
you know uh widespread and so you can
embrace some of these cultural
things but then also add the scientific
uh elements to it and
we're all healthier yeah yeah
well i appreciate it to both of you for
doing that in your own ways already and
for
even coming on this podcast and doing
that in this conversation
merging the science and the mental
health and the faith and community i
think it's so
so important so definitely definitely
appreciate the way you both
contribute and i'll be following the
ongoing work that you all are doing
you're the bridge that gives me hope oh
man
wow i'm honored and listen i need you
all to continue being brilliant because
otherwise i don't know what i'm doing
out here
well we're all working together for the
same cause in a lot of ways so
definitely appreciate dr amy arnstein
lecrae thanks so much for joining on the
addie hour
it's been a pleasure i know this is
going to be enjoyable for folks to
listen to as well i think a lot of
things that will equip people too so
yeah appreciate it honored